c'est donc une peine lourde qui a été
prononcé cet après midi à chalon sur
saône
elle est justifiée par trois éléments a
expliqué la présidente de la cour
d'assises
la gravité des faits les antécédents
judiciaires de l'accusé qui avait déjà
été condamné pour des faits de violence
et puis le comportement de taris qatar
juste après le meurtre à savoir le fait
qu'il a tenté de retirer de l'argent
avec la carte bleue de la victime et
qu'ensuite il est parti au maroc avec
ses enfants avant de se rendre à la
justice lorsque le corps a été découvert
la décision est difficile à comprendre
pour son avocat difficilement
compréhensible pour un homme qui a fait
le choix mais je le rappellerai il
faudra toujours rappeler que cet homme a
fait le choix de revenir pour affronter
ses juges pour permettre d'aborder la
vérité alors qu'il aurait pu rester à
l'étranger qu'il aurait pu rester à
l'abri des poursuites judiciaires
du côté des parties civiles c'est de
soulagement évidemment mais un
soulagement relatif plutôt heureuse
parce que c'est un peu inattendu c'est
vrai que mon avocate elle m'avait
préparé à ce qui est moins après 30 ans
à
c'est pas assez quand on perd un frère
il reviendra pas même dans 30 ans mais
oui je suis assez assez content d'après
je sais qu'il va faire appel donc ça
veut dire revenir dans un an
vu la même chose ça c'est un peu
difficile pour quelqu'un qui qui nous
répètent depuis quatre jours qu'il
assume ses actes comme il fait appel ça
va encore durer un an
donc c'est encore lol ça va se passer à
dijon je vais être une galère encore
donc on va rénumérés tout ce qu'il a
fait là pour notre petit fils est quand
même pin où vit ma femme sur trois
taris qatar a désormais dix jours pour
faire appel de cette décision et espérer
un jugement plus clément